[Musique]
bonjour célia bonjour pas triste bien
bah oui on est très très heureux parce
qu'on se retrouve pour une heure ça
pique nouvelle formule toute la
rédaction est mobilisée ça va être
formidable et puis on va avoir des
choses exceptionnelles d'ailleurs vous
pouvez nous dire à peu près ça alors il
y aura plusieurs invités 1 seront à
notre table dans cette émission donc
deux mairies viennois qui raconteront
leurs actions pour une bonne cause on
sera aussi avec une habitante de maisons
laffitte qui va organiser une vente de
gâteaux dont les bénéfices seront
viendront réfugiés ukrainiens par
exemple et on commence tout de suite
avec un sommaire alors dans cette
émission s'intéressera initiative du
département à des yvelines en concours
d'éloquence nommé articulé depuis le 1er
mars 2022 ce sont 12 illinois qui ont
participé à des ateliers d'art oratoire
on sera avec l'une d'entre eux par
téléphone elle s'appelle laura khomeiny
originaire de bois d'arcy elle vient
d'être élue première dauphine de
l'élection de miss supranational
on reviendra avec elle sur son parcours
au rap et enfin le mois molière revient
à durant tout le mois de juin au
programme 230 manifestations différentes
dans toute la ville de versailles
[Musique]
brasier vous êtes d'accord vous allez
vous nous donnez bas le les infos qu'il
faut retenir pendant l'actualité
ont péri ce week-end orages et grêle le
ministre de l'agriculture et de la
souveraineté alimentaire marque faith no
s'est rendu après né en yvelines ce
jeudi 9 juin objectif constater les
dégâts et soutenir les agriculteurs dont
les récoltes ont été impactés samedi 4
juin une trentaine d'exploitations a été
durement touchée dans le sud des
yvelines mark snow a annoncé que les
dispositifs seraient mis en place bilan
positif pour les navettes autonome
depuis le mois de mars 2021 la ligne 490
constitué de trois navettes autonome
elle desservait la zone d'activités du
pas du lac depuis la gare de saint
quentin en yvelines à montigny le
bretonneux porté par ile-de-france
mobilité et keolis l'expérimentation a
pris fin ce mardi 7 juin des navettes
100% électrique est gratuite pourrait
être déployé plus largement sur le
territoire en fonctionnement depuis
novembre 2000 21 l'écho fourrière
automobile et animales de poissy vient
d'être inaugurée ce mercredi 8 juin
implantée route de 40 sous le projet a
représenté un investissement de 5
millions d'euros depuis le mois de
janvier 950 véhicules et 170 animaux ont
été pris en charge en sport c'est un
match de taille qui attend le rugby-club
de versailles ce dimanche 12 juin
l'équipe versaillaise reçoit le
rugby-club de vincennes à domicile au
staff au stade pop trentaine et
rencontres qui leur assurer une montée
en fédérale 2 en cas de victoire
vainqueurs au match aller 21 à 17
l'équipe à 4 points à rattraper coup
d'envoi du match à 15 heures et puis
toujours à versailles cette fois ci en
culture le 26e mois molière a débuté la
manifestation autour du théâtre et de la
musique revient chaque année pendant
tout le mois de juin au programme
concerts ou encore théâtre 230 spectacle
spectacles différents sont prévus au
programme et réservations sur le site de
la ville de versailles merci vous qu
justice pour toutes ces informations
vous l'avez dit c'est une édition un peu
particulière ce mois molière oui ce que
c'est le 400e anniversaire maintenant
tout le monde sait que vos liens réunion
ce sont 22 1 on se disait non c'est 400
ont fait farsi pour savoir faire une
soustraction oui mais en tout cas
matière à bulle fr faut-il bonjour donc
vous allez nous parler du programme de
la programmation de ce mois molière oui
célia en fait pendant tout ce mois
molière se sucer succéderont pardon des
comédies des animations des expositions
des spectacles ou encore même des
conférences pour célébrer le célèbre
dramaturge jean baptiste poquelin alias
molière dans les plus beaux lieux de la
ville de versailles les yvelinois
pourront découvrir ou redécouvrir des
pièces emblématiques les fourberies de
scapin l'avare ou encore le misanthrope
au total vous l'avez dit c'est plus de
deux cent trente représentations qui
auront lieu tout le mois de juin ce mois
molière est porté par le maire de
versailles françois de mazières depuis
maintenant 26 ans stéphanie tesson
metteuse en scène nous parle de l'esprit
que lui évoque le molière écouter le
maire de versailles françois de mazières
depuis
24 ans entretient une sorte de fidélité
à l'égard de ma troupe comme à l'égard
de beaucoup d'autres artistes d'ailleurs
qu'ils font partie de ce mois molière
qui est devenu une sorte d'institution
mythique presque semblable avignon en
tout cas au niveau du département des
yvelines il réunit autour de lui des
artistes qui lui sont fidèles depuis une
vingtaine d'années qui ont en commun
d'aimer travailler dans ce lieu par
rapport à auzon historique qui ne dégage
et oui des ondes historique puisque
molière et intimement lié à la ville de
versailles il jouer ses pièces dans les
jardins du château lors des
divertissements et royaux de louis xiv
si vous demandez pourquoi pourquoi
pourquoi versa ici intouchable hier oui
y'a quand même ce lien eh oui
molière il y avait un très fort le un
très fort lien est donc cette année
comme vous l'avez dit est particulière
puisqu'il s'agit aussi de fêter les
quatre cents ans alors difficile de
parler de tout le programme et on peut
retenir quelques dates comme les
fourberies de scapin les 12 et 13 juin
ou encore le médecin malgré lui les 24
et 25 juin aux grandes écuries alors
patrice et là justin est ce que vous
vous avez des pièces de molière favorite
j'adore donjon j'adore tortue
oui enfin mais c'est vrai qu'il ya des
pièces moins connues qui sont aussi
absolument formidable on en reparlera
peut-être tout à l'heure avec de nos
invités mais c'est vrai que c est une
oeuvre considérable évidemment mondial
et on s'aperçoit à chaque fois qu'on
joue à quel point ces éternels et ses
actuels nous font c'est ça qui est
formidable quand vous parlez quand vous
prenez tartu c'est vrai que quand vous
voyez les gens qui vous mentent au nom
de la religion il va quand même beaucoup
à
une autre date du coup à ne pas manquer
durant ce mois molière c'est le
spectacle de stéphanie tesson convient
d'éviter ces verts paradis à la mis en
scène une dizaine de mini saynètes pour
célébrer la nature et donc son but c'est
de conjuguer la culture de l'esprit et
la culture de la terre on l'écoutant bas
notre travail
consiste en des promenades et spectacle
promenade spectacle promenade ça dit
bien ce que savait y est c'est à dire la
déambulation et le rapport aux décors
naturels est aussi important que la le
produit artistique qu'on propose aux
spectateurs et le spectacle de cette
année en témoigne puisqu'il s'agit de
vert paradis
cette expression qui était un poème de
baudelaire des fleurs du mal
et c'est vert paradis des amours
enfantines
ce sont ceux que nous essayons de
ressusciter aujourd'hui à l'occasion de
ce spectacle qui se déploie dans tout le
lan toute enceinte du potager qui écorne
là ou alors est-ce que qu'est ce que ça
vous inspire vert paradis j'ai dit au
potager du roi d'abord c'est un lieu
magnifique
c'est très sympa de venir dans la quête
et qui était le jardinier qui était
quelques rides potager du roi et
déambuler dans ce lieu sublime avec des
textes et stéphanie des sons et une
metteur en scène exceptionnelle donc oui
ça se faisait très très attirant sans
qui cette époque
en tout cas la sélectionner plein
d'oeuvre des pièces de théâtre de la
poésie de la littérature je vous en dis
pas plus je vous laisse découvrir tout
ça le samedi 11 juin et le dimanche 12
juin au potager du roi l'entrée est à 12
euros d'ailleurs tous les tarifs 12 e du
mur molière sont relativement bas en
fait cela m'a de la gratuité à 18 euros
c'est aussi ça l'esprit molière la
culture pour tous exact
et donc pour en parler avec nous du mois
molière aujourd'hui sur ce plateau nous
avons carlo boso bonjour vous êtes
metteur en scène et co directeur de
l'académie internationale des arts et du
spectacle de versailles oui cochard et
olivier certains vous vous êtes
le créateur d'un stand un
blog qui réunit des articles des
interviews des passionnés d'histoire
vous êtes avec nous pour parler du mois
molière carlo boso vous vous allez
mettre en place plusieurs
représentations les fourberies de scapin
et le triomphe le d'arlequin pourquoi
ces pièces là pourquoi cette épicerie à
des gens naquet et nous on était chargé
des pouilly 2008 et par la ville et
d'animer les places les jardins avec des
pièces de théâtre et bien entendu cette
année c'est l'année molière alors qu'ils
ont choisi les pièces qui sont liées à
quel que ça pète russe à démolir et vous
brisez scalpel et
les amis savent que ça veut dire le
toupet toutes les pièces et que ça peut
être les plus intéressantes pour nous
pour le faire mais surtout pour les
jeunes gens qui quittent fréquenté
l'académie et qu'ils ont l'occasion
avait pendant cette période des
pratiques et molière de découvrir nos
légionnaires oui oui ça veut dire cette
académie s'est formée par des musées
groupe une équipe et artistique qui
encadre des jeunes gens tu es pour
devenir professionnel d'accord est
toujours là si je les joue toujours
après ce pire depuis 2008 on a fait trop
sentir la présentation dans les cadres
et membres lierre et adopter le dock et
lieu par là on est dans la place du
marché j'en dis tout près de chez vous
et on est un grand siècle et saviez tous
les tous les samedis dimanches et
changer d'endroit
l'image
de la décentralisation mais dans la
ville
par des inflexions du sud non j
la commedia dell'arte 210 tandis que le
lierse as inscrit le nom d oui j'écris
là il ya des thématiques que des
molières qui sont repris et qui par
molière il arrivait dans l'armée d'après
vous dire j'ai parlé des molières
c'était gênant hôtel phénoménale et pour
nous surtout pour les jeunes parce que
les 90% tdr j'étais seul lèvres ils sont
touchés contre les mariages forcés
salive et ça c est la bataille terrible
des maux liés à ces contrées malaise est
fauché d'un période avec et la famille
n'avait aucun droit et alors c'est très
intéressante pour les jeunes à pratiquer
molière guerre c'était chose existe
encore assez intéressante est allé
d'état il avait dit à l'officier
et la vente avec les italiens jettent a
très fortement les raids avaient partagé
les théâtres et les petits bourgs bombe
avec la compagnie de bien coller les que
se tenait ce week-end à québec mais
celui là est ma cliente est déjà né
durant p il ya eu des échanges très
forte
dans ces formidables comédiens de se
promener dans l'est alors oui comment y
ait des horaires ou alors oui oui je
place du marché
si jamais les horaires ça aussi mais les
citoyens les gens s'est habitué à savoir
et après les programmes très bien de
réparer en ligne sur le site de la ville
sur le site de
toutes les informations y en a beaucoup
parce qu'on a deux cent trente noms tout
les impôts le rapport
est donc devant vous en faites vous avez
le masque de molière et vous a fait un
allin basque masques de théâtre elle est
chic et
branché oui qu'est-ce que c'est qu'est
ce que vous pouvez nous expliquer ce que
c'est en fait le alors il est certain
que vous êtes vous êtes en tire je ne
suis pas anti coeur non non non moi je
suis blogueur avant longueur
journalistes et puis basta compagne des
antiquaires de versailles qui a qui ont
qui ont voulu fêter les 400 ans de fin
de mois guerre et on s'est dit que les
objets avaient des histoires et on
voulait que
les objets parler
nous avons ainsi un invité car le bozo
de façon à ce que à ce qui nous est un
petit peu en scène tous et tous et
toutes ces objets par rapport
c'est un vieux il se rendit nerf je sais
pas si tu connaissais c'était un peu mou
clean
depuis les chocs partout on peut avoir
des objets un prix
un prix fava très cher et voilà et on
peut partir avec par exemple un katana
comme ça
quintana c'est un objet qui datent fin
du xvème siècle le le tour et de
l'époque meiji c'est en quoi ça si en
séance et en ivoire matin c'est du mort
fin je sais pas si vous voyez mais les
morses alors on a référence et donc et
voilà c'est fait comme ça aujourd'hui
comment
on fait
mepha voilà donc en fait il ya quarante
40 antiquaires dans ce far dans ce
quartier et ben voilà donc on avoue bien
s'il ya des
fêtes et vous tu vois un autre dans
l'histoire il est extraordinaire et
décale dit molière la rédac c'est
parfait on est dans à l'époque gervais
rival de ce très beau voyage dans
l'époque de molière
comme ça c'est président à
la place du marché d'une an il ya plein
milieu
de
la semaine des collectionneurs voilà
comme ça jusqu'à la date exacte e m'en
aller j'ai une grosse main à la
merci beaucoup merci
merci mathilde aussi pour toute cette
information sur le mois molière
[Musique]
mais dit que ce n'était pas ce qu'on
sait pour rejoindre en plaques seulement
c'est qu'on va voter oui en principe
eric bacqua y ait beaucoup de gens qui
ne vont pas voter y ait beaucoup
d'abstentionnistes 60% des taux
d'abstention sait jamais mais enfin
quand même on va lire des députés les 12
et 19 voix pour ça et on voudrait bien
savoir nous justement à quoi ça sert un
député alors notre quelqu'un dans la
rédaction qui connaissait par coeur oui
c'est bixente
bon jour
il faut commencer par présenter ce qu'un
député un député qu'est ce que c'est
c'est celui qui siège à l'assemblée
nationale dans l'hémicycle il y à 577
sièges numérotés et remises en vue tous
les cinq ans la france est donc divisée
en 577 circonscriptions et nous dans les
yvelines on en a 12 mai à quoi voilà
quoi sert un député quelles sont les
missions est ce que vous savez à peu
près bas mais pas de gens qui gèrent
voter les lois exactement la page de la
mission exacte
déposer des propositions
actuellement exactement déposé des
propositions de loi alors que c'est le
gouvernement et les projets de loi c'est
ça en fait ils partagent le pouvoir
législatif avec les sénateurs en cas de
désaccord les députés leur rôle ils ont
le dernier mot les députés en cas de
désaccord avec le sénat il tranche voilà
ils peuvent perdre où ils peuvent
renverser le gouvernement deuxième
mission exactement le contrôle
gouvernemental donc un pays doit
questionner sur la politique publique
mise en oeuvre par le gouvernement l'un
des pouvoirs de l'assemblée nationale
c'est comme vous l'avez dit patrice la
signature et le vote d'une motion de
censure en cas de majorité dans
l'hémicycle le premier ministre doit
remettre la démission de son
gouvernement au président et enfin en
local le député il sert aussi à
faire remonter les préoccupations des
citoyens
quelques petites anecdotes à savoir
maintenant au tour des députés d'abord
un niveau de la parité pour les
sélestadiens commencer
voilà il n'ya pas encore y'a pas encore
55 ans exactement en fait on peut pas
vraiment faire 50 50 en effectif dans
l'assemblée nationale parce que par
rapport aux gens qui se présentent et
qui sont élus mais aussi
politique au niveau des partis
politiques ils sont soumis e à la parité
la parité il m'a aidé à mon
parti doit présenter autant d'hommes que
de femmes sinon il est sanctionné d'une
amende en effet ou plutôt il n'est pas
récompensé par des dotations publiques
en fait par exemple entre 2012 et 2017
comme il n'y avait que 42% des
candidatures enregistrées aux
législatives qui était féminine les
différents partis politiques ont renoncé
à près de 28 millions d'euros quand même
c'est une zone de dotation publique pour
cette non respect de la parité les
partis politiques ont préféré donc
désigner des hommes quitte à recevoir
moins d'argent deuxième question le
cumul des mandats avec ali les mandats
de politique locale on peut pas être
député à la première place d'une
institution locale par air mer mais
plutôt frais partout et beaucoup de
députés verts c'est vrai que depuis la
loi du non-cumul pouvait paraître bête
mais le champêtre quoi on peut pas être
député maire on veut pas être député et
président de département ni président de
région ni président d'agglomération par
contre les députés avoir un mandat en
tant que conseiller régional aussi fait
original mais si pâle départementale
exactement
par et enfin une bien une question qui
nous intéresse tous combien est payé un
député arabe alors ça vous le savez le
direct dans les environs en salaires
pour 6000 euros par mois 7000 euros je
dirais exactement
7200 39 95 euros
cette somme elle compte plusieurs choses
elle compte le salaire de base autour de
5600 euros et deux indemnités
l'indemnité de résidence à 168 euros et
l'indemnité de fonction à 1448 euros en
est ça correspond un à 5691 d'interviews
plus y'a pas toi y'a pas toi
s'arrêter de travailler quoi comme ça
que le travail et sachant que c'est un
vrai problème cela vient de devenir le
paiement par des sables est-ce qu'il
faut payer très cher les hommes
politiques ou pas fallait pour attirer
des gens c'est vrai problème s'ils ont
un mandat en plus de conseiller local à
côté seulement voilà d'entrée du coup
parler de du bac après à merci
maintenant avec les
bichonne tout de suite su enchaîner sur
le bac c'est pas du tout le même domaine
du coup ko passe de l'un à l'autre il
n'y a pas de souci combien de députés
ont le bac
pays dont ils sont peut-être une bonne
partie quoique pour être député sachez
que pour se présenter il suffit d'être
majeur 18 ans d'être de nationale
française et de joueurs de tous ses
droits
politiques et civiques vous savez qu'il
ya un candidat qui était condamné pour
assassinat
c'est le sud de la france qui se
présente et qui dit dans ses
propositions et dit quelques cas quasi
judiciaires ne devrait plus pouvoir se
ne plus jamais pouvoir se présentait
donc si jamais il était élu mon avis ne
le sera pas mais démissionner
immédiatement
et alors vous avez rencontrées vous des
lycéens c'est ça qui préparent le bac au
temps du muet donc ne n'iront pas voter
parce que pour la plupart ils sont
mineurs quoique certains qui sont en
début d'année son y sont des chercheurs
mais on les a j'allais rencontrer pour
en savoir plus sur la nouvelle formule
puisque finalement elle est assez
obscure pour nous qui n'avons qui avons
passé le bac il ya quelques années même
pour nous pourquoi voilà on comprend pas
forcément tous moi je sais que j'ai
passé 5 5 6 ans un peu plus et je
comprends pas forcément tous les deux si
vous leur passé aujourd'hui ils sont
révisés pour ses gaules
ca réalisé navette en passant public et
s'est fait représenter
ce que tout le monde sait en tout cas
c'est que maintenant contrairement à
avant il n'y a plus de section le ssl il
ya un tronc commun avec des spécialités
à choisir trois pour être exact pour le
baccalauréat général dans le contrôle
continu on retrouve histoire géographie
les deux langues vivantes l'enseignement
scientifique le sport un des
enseignements de spécialité donc qui a
été choisi parmi les trois mais qui a
été abandonné aux premières et
l'enseignement moral et civique si on
enlève les épreuves orales et écrites de
français il restait donc aux élèves à
passer quatre épreuves cette année en
terminale les deux spécialités choisies
parmi treize possibles entre art
histoire maths littérature il ya un
grand panel de spécialités voilà et qui
sont les deux plus grands coefficients
16 et la philosophie et le fameux grand
oral pour le bac technologique l'éco
efficience a à peu près les mêmes n'y a
pas trop de deux variations et comme
vous l'avez dit c'est l'air valascia les
à la rencontre des lycéens pour leur
demander ce qu'ils pensaient de cette
nouvelle formule je pense que l'idée de
pouvoir choisir d'espèces différentes
c'était une bonne idée mais en fait le
fait de choisir en hausse pda fin de la
seconde c'est assez problématique
surtout pour les personnes qui n'a pas
de prendre un peu essuyé les plâtres ce
qu'on a été les testeurs mais je trouve
que c'est bien parce que il ya une
grosse partie en continu continu donc si
on travaille toute l'année ça se voit
et l'idée des spécialités ça permet de
vraiment être évalué sur ce qu'on aime
mais pas sur des matières combien de
pages en démat il ya quand même deux
trois trucs à revoir comme les maths qui
ont été supprimés qui reviennent
et puis on n'est pas forcément
enfin les profs sont un peu moins formés
sur comment nous enseigne et que donc à
l'heure actuelle il ne reste plus que
deux épreuves à passer pour les lycéens
la philosophie le 15 juin prochain et du
20 juin au 1er juillet le fameux grand
oral où il présente deux questions axées
chacune eu autour d'une de leurs deux
spécialités elles sont choisies par les
étudiants et ça peut aller de voilà de
la réflexion marketing autour d'une
marque à une analyse d'oeuvre artistique
selon les sensibilités de chacun n'y a
pas de limite le mot grand oral ça peut
faire un peu stressé d'ailleurs on
entend que ça fait qu'aller au cours de
l' énorme exactement quoi en fait en
discutant avec eux on ne discutant avec
eux on apprend que lycéens ils sont les
événements en tout cas ils ne sont pas
si stressée que ça regarde c'est bien
toujours un peu stressé mais en vrai
elle est le plus gros du stress étaient
les spécialités coefficient 16la la
philo il gros toile le stress retombe un
peu quoi au début ça me stresse beaucoup
déjà parce qu'on en parle beaucoup mais
quand j'ai passé l'oral blanc je me suis
rendu compte que c'était pas grand chose
en fait faut juste parlé fin minutes
hyper long le prépare depuis environ
mars puisqu'on avait fini le programme
éligibles à l'écrit moi je pense que je
suis assez près des justes à revoir un
peu mes questions et herat mais du coup
je pense que ça ira donc voilà après
cette ultime épreuve il ne restera plus
qu'à attendre l'instant fatidique des
résultats qui tomberont le mardi 5
juillet prochain les encore où il a eu
la philo c'est encore importante la
philo c'est coefficient les huit vit
actuellement est papa pop a pour tout
les toutes les balles ya un tronc commun
donc tout laissait trouvera son qui va
se battre parce la fille lola le 15 juin
un coefficient 8 exactement c'est ça le
mathématiques par exemple qu'il revienne
en option l'année prochaine mais si on
ne les a pas pris en spécialité cette
année les premières et terminales n'ont
pas de mathématiques mais d'après ce que
j'ai compris ce que cette année y'a du y
ait beaucoup de contrôle continu non
exactement contrôle continu à si on peut
je ne sais pas si on peut re voir
l'infographie la photographie du
contrôle continu ses 40% lors pour
certains parce que j'aime entendez
d'aider des élèves des étudiants qui
disait on est déjà sûr de l'avoir congo
exactement c'est ça ce que j'ai
rencontré ceux qui ont bien travaillé
sur l'année oui après le problème c'est
que ceux qui ont fait une moins bonne
moyenne générale parce que au long de
l'année ils n'avaient pas forcément à
tous de suivre ou quoi ils sont
le jour j et puis finalement qui
réussissent et qui ont des bannettes
donc ça dépend axa im a pour lui et là
de quoi continuer à laquelle sera la
plupart sont satisfaits jusqu il y à
quelques améliorations à apporter parce
que c'est un nouveau système mais les
lycéens sont a priori au courant que ça
va s'amuser ils sont un peu les tests
quoi
de
plus que savez vous du genre à les
appuyer non pas d'abord pour le demander
merci beaucoup plus été en tout cas ces
informations avec les députés ils vont
partir directement l'assemblée sont qui
sont élus c'est ça ceux qui sont pas lus
et ses quais puis les lycéens que le bac
vont pouvoir prendre le large
on va parler de large avec michael we do
not
alors vous avez vous avez rencontré un
yvelinois mais qui pas n'importe quel
l'illinois qui est d'être un très grand
navigateur ça devient un très grand
navigateur c'est louis burton louis
burton qui va participer au vendée
arctique est ce que vous connaissez ou
pas autour de sa vie l'homme y c'est un
peu le même principe sa part des sables
d'olonne mais par contre il va avoir une
boucle qui va être faite autour de
l'islande alors on peut le dire cette
vie nous à loubersan on peut dire qu'il
n'a pas froid aux yeux on savait il a 37
ans il fait partie des meilleurs
skippers du moment où vous disiez
patrice laurent boli temps à participer
à cette course de 3500 milles nautiques
d'une rare intensité qui va lui demander
beaucoup d'énergie dans des conditions
météorologiques très compliqué son
bateau au bureau vallée devra passer au
dessus de lit sont je le disais avant de
revenir en vendée il devra sûrement
faire beaucoup de manoeuvres ou burton
nous présente les principales
difficultés qui va rencontrer pendant
son périple
ça va être assez rock'n'roll avec
beaucoup de changements de voiles et il
va falloir essayer ne pas casser les
bateaux dans ces passages de front et
puis ensuite on va arriver dans une zone
où il fait vraiment très froid avec une
difficulté qu'elle est au relief de
l'islande puisque ça culminent à 2200
mètres de haut donc on va avoir des
zones sans vent et des zones
probablement avec des boules et
d'accélération et puis après si on
arrive à faire le tour de l'islande va
redescendre entre le groenland et
l'islande est donc là bas il ya la glace
qui est pas très loin
donc il va falloir être vigilant sur les
éventuels décrocher d'icebergs etc
et puis redescendre cette fois ci plus
tôt portant avec du vent potable
potentiellement assez france jusqu'aux
sables-d'olonne
objectif pour louis burton tester la
fiabilité de son nouveau bureau vallée 3
pour le préparer au maximum pour le
prochain vendée globe qui sera
programmée en quelle année patrice 2002
mémoire 2024 c'est ça un bateau qui
avait eu un problème
jacques vabre l'illinois avait dû
abandonner malheureusement en 2021 après
quelques heures de course sur la transat
jacques vabre mais pas le vendée globe
parce qu'ils avaient fini troisièmes
cette fois ci le navigateur veut bien
évidemment terminer la course et si
possible viser le plus haut possible on
écoute c'est assez possible de viser
dans les cinq premiers et puis après
c'est le petit plus c'est d'aller
chercher d'aller chercher le podium mais
c'est vrai qu'il ya trois bateaux avec
23 couple bateau skipper qui sont très
performants avec des gars qui ont des
bateaux très rapide et surtout qu'ils
ont leur bateau depuis trois ans qu'on
fait le vendée globe avec don qui le
connaissent sur le bout des doigts
et donc ils vont être difficiles à aller
chercher alors cette course
intermédiaire entre les grandes courses
du calendrier sera tout de même
qualificatif pour le prochain vendée
globe louis burton aura donc à coeur de
terminer cette course le plus haut
possible rendez vous dans deux grosses
semaines il a dû à deux semaines plus ou
moins 48 heures au mieux pour connaître
son résultat d'accord et il visera top 5
si possible s'il a déjà un gros palmarès
au palmarès où exactement il a fini 7e
de la transat jacques vabre s'est il ya
quand même quelques années il a fini 7e
en 2016 du vendée globe là où il n'était
pas forcément attendu est troisième
également du dernier vendée globe alors
qu'ils n'étaient pas attendus du tout
même s'il avait un bateau quand même qui
était qui était assez fiable mais vous
qui le connaissez bien comment comment
parce que le dire allemand les marins
c'est des bretons ses défenseurs qui
évite le relais mais comment quand on
est dans les yvelines quand on vous lit
dans les yvelines quand on a grandi dans
les yvelines on devient un bain de ce
niveau là alors moi je le connais quand
même depuis quelques années je le suis
depuis 2015 2016 alors au début je ne
savais pas du tout qu'il était ivre est
justement pour les raisons que vous
venez de citer je pensais qu'il était
breton qu'il était peut-être normand pas
du tout il a grandi dans les yvelines et
à la celle les bordes pendant de
nombreuses années il est ensuite allé à
rambouillet il a étudié à rambouillet et
ce qui me disait c'est que tous les
week-ends il allait faire de la voile
avec ses parents c'est pour ça qu'ils
aillent aux cibles ou sur un bateau on
connaît pas forcé de breton pour devenir
champion il y avait d'autres yvelinois
aussi pour préciser qu'ils ont participé
au vendée globe c'était en 2016 il y
avait tant guy delamotte qui participent
et sur initiative coeur qui n'avait pas
terminé la course et il y avait
également à l'époque
eric maillaud aussi qui a participé à la
course donc y avait trois illinois qui
était présent sur le vendée globe c'est
pas mal sur une édition et éric bellion
va partir c'est de participer au
prochain vendée globe également un très
bien bon ben alors arrêtez de nous
parler maintenant de d'un concours de
beauté
en
fait il faut savoir que michael ne
choisit pas les sujets où le bateau
aura et le rove et dit bonjour
comment ça va ça va très bien merci nous
avons été un peu fait courir un
travail
etc te ment alors l'aura du coup est ce
que vous connaissez miss supranational
ou pis si
justin peut-être non mais beaucoup moins
qu'au miss france par exemple non il
faut dire expliquer alors c'est quoi me
situe prénationale alors c'est l'un des
plus grands voulez parler de tobrouk
travailler
non en fait on a cinq grands concours à
l'international et miss supranational
c'est le quatrième d'entre eux doit donc
voilà j'ai participé au concours
national qui s'était tenue le 5 juin
mais quand et supranationaux vraiment on
a l'impression que tous acceptent
d'autres pays que la france n'ont cessé
ces franco français oui mais c'est
vraiment pour l'international pour la
tendance et orange où il ya une vocation
nationale
vraiment oui c'est l'image de la france
dans le monde au fonds voilà seize ans
d'accord
votre palmarès et bien vers dauphine
vente
jusqu'à la fin quoi vous êtes là et oded
c'est peut-être boisé peut-être pas
qu'est ce qu'on ressent quand attention
et moment j'y croyais pas forcément
parce que j'avais reçu deux prix juste
avant j'ai reçu le prix du dynamisme et
le prix du public donc je me suis dit
bon ils vont peut-être pas me donner la
l'écharpé tu sais je pensais pas
forcément à voir la couronne donc
j'étais juste surprise et je pense qu'on
le voit sur les images où je suis un peu
interloqué je regarde mes parents au
loin et je me dis mon tour n'était la
wii avec mon était là on a réuni les
amis même ma petite nièce de quatre ans
qu'il a donné corps et âme pour le
soutenir
on avait filmé d'ailleurs nos reportages
sur tv 78 litres et dynamique et
peut-être que ça sera une miss suprême
faut dire que les oreilles de bois
d'arcy cassé sa boîte 6 à 25 ans ça je
me trompe comme quoi j'avais bien
travaillé
et le concours s'est passé à roubaix
c'est pas tout à fait est-ce qu'on avait
les miss roubaix c'est vraiment le
premier concours en france et donc pour
garder la tradition ça s'est passé
là-bas j'ai pas quand même cette petite
déception de finir deuxièmes finalement
d'être si proche de la victoire approche
peut-être si j'avais eu aucun prix avant
est ce que vraiment sur le moment je
pensais vraiment ne rien avoir comme
j'avais déjà eu des prix du public je me
suis dit voilà j'ai déjà été à bien
vérifier bien on a été assez
reconnaissant mon parcours donc comme je
m'y attendais pas du tout a finalement
pas tant que ça et puis je trouve que
c'est une bonne classe j'avais jamais vu
de concours de beauté y en a il est pas
mal de filles qui avait déjà concouru
donc je me suis dit que c'était un bon
défi de relever les grosses comment tout
ça comme on sait que vous avez pardon
les bêtes ou si comme moi
vous aimez ces passionnés par ce qui
m'intéresse c'est le délire hervé
développe comme comment le premier
concours de beauté que vous avez fait
c'est quoi avais tu étais celui ci je
suis leurs amis c'était sur un coup de
tête en fait j'ai vu une publication sur
les réseaux sociaux on expliquait que
les candidatures étaient ouvertes
c'était la miss international qui
parlait qui expliquait que voilà on
pouvait on pouvait se lancer et je me
suis vue peut aller pourquoi pas
après tout 25 ans je pense que c'est un
bon âge pour pour se lancer là-dedans et
devrait fonctionner je voulais savoir
vous avez peut-être continuer là dedans
fin alors je ne sais pas si je
continuerai les concours de beauté parce
que c'était vraiment une expérience je
voulais pas en faire un métier où
vraiment lancée dans tout ce qui est
médias réseaux sociaux etc c'était
vraiment pour un peu entrevoir ce monde
ça m'a beaucoup plu mais à côté de ça je
fais du droit et je suis quand même
assez passionné par ce que parce que
j'étais étudiante oui je suis encore
étudiante il me reste encore un an de
droits à poursuivre dame du tunnel et
canton des premières dauphines de de ce
qu'on trouve l'esprit prénationale ça
implique des devoirs vous avez des idées
des missions de représentation des
mythes alors on voit bassil a flambé de
6 la miss actuelle ne peut pas ne peut
pas faire ses missions on est appelé à
la fête à se substituer à elle et après
on a peut-être des concours
internationaux auxquels on peut être
envoyées et également des petits points
de petits événements par ci par là
surtout je pense ça sera dans les
yvelines en premier lieu je ne peux pas
me déplacer dans toute la france et plus
la miss la miss nationale qui va le
faire mais voilà on a des petits des
petits événements par ci par là qui sont
un peu plus un peu moins prenants et
pour cet événement là vous aviez choisi
une robe aussi un peu particulière qui
représente les yvelines oui ou non il y
aurait alors j'ai fait un costume
régional et je l'avais basé sur
versailles parce que donc moi j'étais
ile de france j'étais quand même
rattachée à versailles donc j'ai voulu
vraiment faire un petit clin d'oeil est
donc en fait c'est avec une amie marine
jouant ou qui avait donc des études de
faim dans la mode et voilà elle m'a
aidée à faire à faire mon costume et
donc on a fait une petite crinoline avec
un costume en toile de jouy
j'avais vraiment on était tous émus line
et le coach m'a beaucoup plu donc agité
oui mais je l'avais dessinée j'ai
vraiment à coeur de tout faire de a à z
que ce soit parce qu'on n'avait pas le
défi à réaliser et donc j'ai voulu
affaires bas mon costume régional j'ai
voulu aussi créer ma robe du grand final
est aussi fermée vidéos etc et pour ça
je me suis entouré de tous mes amis et
de toutes les personnes qui débutait un
peu et donc on a on a constitué une
bonne équipe et c'était comme ça pour
toutes les miss où c'était juste pour
vous qui vous êtes concernant ce projet
là noté votre robe alors il ya des mises
qui ont fait appel à leur mairie qui ont
enfin on leur a prêté des costumes elles
se sont même pas les robes de soirée il
ya des partenariats qui ont été des mois
c'est vrai que j'avais à coeur de garder
mon costume par la suite et j'ai bien
fait parce que donc je vais le donner à
ma petite nièce qu'il a essayé qu'il
adore
mais voilà ça me tenait à coeur vraiment
tout faire moi-même et de le faire avec
l'aide de tous les proches et l'a dit ou
fait des études de droit c'est quoi la
suite elle voulait vous les fait pas
j'aimerais bien être notaire ouais donc
ces huit endroits aujourd'hui j'ai
appris que j'avais valider ma septième
année donc l'installation
c'est que les bonnes nouvelles qui
tombent donc voilà mais je pense que je
continuerai plutôt dans ce domaine
domaine du notariat c'est bien je crois
que c'est un peu compliqué c'est ça on
peut pas être la foi de nos terres et
faire l'émission demi c'est un peu
compliqué de la société de palladio que
je serai titré après c'est vrai qu'on a
un petit devoir de réserve tout ce qui
est émission de télé etc c'est plus
compliqué de pouvoir s'afficher au
nom d'allah non mais bien pouvait venir
réussi à ôter les retours notables de
drainer mais on a vraiment une
déontologie qui est très stricte et on
peut pas on peut pas en fait on ne peut
pas interviewer en nos terres on ne peut
pas passer un peu à l ensemble les
médecins c'est un peu pareil
oui c'est vrai qu'ils sont contrôlés par
l'ordre des médecins
heiarii gallia il ya des d'auteur qui
participe à des émissions autant
spécimens comme publicité je serai ce
métier
merci beaucoup je crois qu'il faut avoir
des notions d'éloquence quand on est
miss oui mais j'ai tout appris sur place
donc avant le coup ça a vraiment été un
court temps
c'est pour ça que vous avez choisi
plutôt le notariat que quatre avocate
par exemple non c'est parce que je suis
un homme plus plus solides
fondées le fond du huawei sur des études
je me suis dit que c'était mieux
d'accompagner les particuliers dans leur
projet de vie que les assister dans un
tribunal
merci beaucoup leur
merci bonjour je parlais de lever
l'audience parce que nous il y à une
initiative initiative du département des
yvelines donc c'est il s'agit
d'articuler donc depuis le 1er mars 2000
2022 12 illinois ont participé à des
ateliers d'art oratoire et donc objectif
passer prendre confiance en eux gagné en
aisance dans la prise de parole et
développer aussi leurs compétences et
nous nous sommes rendus à un atteignent
à un atelier regarder
[Musique]
ouais ça c'est bien c'est la dernière
ligne droite pour naïma avec son texte
sur les cons elle va participer au
concours d'éloquence depuis le 1er mars
cet habitant de conflans sainte honorine
participent à des ateliers d'art
oratoire je me suis aperçu dès la
première séance que en fait
se bat non en fait on sait pas parler et
non c'est même pas écouter les autres
petit à petit en fait nan je me suis
prise au jeu et maintenant je me dis non
seulement tu vas y aller tu vas gagner
aussi un pur qu'à faire on fait bien les
choses et lui donc j'ai pris confiance
en moi en fait ce jour là isabelle men
l'atelier cette professeur de théâtre
donne les dernières techniques d'art
oratoire il est plus facile pour
quelqu'un d'intelligent
d'être parfois qu'on
que pour un con
d'être intelligent
depuis le 1er mars 2022 ils sont douze
personnes à suivre ces ateliers tous les
mardis les initiatives mises en place
par le conseil départemental des
yvelines l'idée pour nous était que les
personnes puissent
quel que soit l'environnement que ce
soit dans le cercle familial dans le
cercle social bien sûr professionnels
aiment beaucoup plus à l'aise
ce raté mais pas tout seul
ça
originaire des comores à midi juriste de
formation elle vit à mantes la jolie a
décidé de participer à cet atelier pour
être plus à l'aise lors de ses
entretiens d'embauché quand je suis venu
ça m'a intéressé parce que je trouve que
j'évolue en fait petit à petit à partir
de ce qu'on fait tous les jours qu'il
est mardi il ya une grande évolution
parce qu'avant quand j'ai parlé j'ai
tremblé tout maintenant je vois que ça
va si c'est diminuer
après trois mois de travail tous les
participants sont prêts pour le concours
prévu le 10 juin à la médiathèque blaise
cendras de conflans sainte honorine
[Musique]
et nous sommes aux lignes je crois oui
par téléphone oui avec un midi marras
kaki king et qu'on a vu là et qui
participe à ce concours d'éloquence
amedi vous êtes là
vous nous entendez
un petit problème
de connexion
plaisir c'est ici elle vous attendez à
midi les plus tard c'est pour ça alors
je crois que l'on me dit dans
l'oreillette que c'est bon c'est bon à
ton avis dit bonjour
wario
ça va
[Rires]
nous ça va très bien mais nous on n'est
pas stressé mais vous c'est donc peu
tout le concours
jeudi le concours que vous allez passer
le concours d'éloquence et c'est bien
tout c'est donc combien de temps
alors vous avez choisi un thème qui nous
a interpellé un je crois que c'est le
thème si vous avez de confirmer le top
coudurier choisissez c'est quoi un con
c'est bien ça
non
[Musique]
cotées au problème de son
on va peut-être venir avec vous tout
honneur parce que là on vous entend pas
ce que pour faire pour converser avec
vous on vient vers vous tout à l'heure à
midi et b pour l'instant on va revenir
avec vous justin nos salaires
sur la qualité dans les yvelines alors
après les intempéries ce week end orage
de grêle le ministre de l'agriculture et
de la souveraineté alimentaire mark snow
s'est rendu à brunet en yvelines ce 9
juin objectif constater les dégâts et
soutenir les agriculteurs dont les
récoltes ont été impactés samedi 4 juin
une trentaine d'exploitations a durement
été touché dont le sud des yvelines marc
fesneau a annoncé que des dispositifs
seraient mis en place bilan positif pour
les navettes autonome depuis le mois de
mars 2021 la ligne 490 constitué de
trois navettes autonome des cervélo
d'activités du pas du lac est depuis la
gare de saint quentin en yvelines à
montigny le bretonneux porté par
ile-de-france mobilité et keolis et
l'expérimentation a pris fin ce mardi 7
juin elle ses navettes 100% électrique
est gratuite pourrait être déployé plus
largement sur le territoire en
fonctionnement depuis novembre 2000 21
l'écho fourrière automobile et animales
de poissy elle vient d'être inaugurée ce
mercredi 8 juin implantée route de 40
sous le projet a représenté un
investissement de 5 millions d'euros est
depuis le mois de janvier 950 véhicules
et 170 animaux ont été pris en charge et
puis en sport c'est un match de taille
qui attend le rugby-club de versailles
ce dimanche 12 juin l'équipe
versaillaise reçoit le rugby-club de
vincennes à domicile au stade
porchefontaine une rencontre qui leur
assurer une montée en fédérale 2 en cas
de victoire vainqueurs au match aller 21
à 17 l'équipe à 4 points à rattraper le
coup d'envoi du match à 15 heures et
puis toujours à versailles cette fois ci
en culture le 26e mois molière a débuté
la manifestation autour du théâtre et de
la musique revient chaque année pendant
tout le mois de juin au programme
concerts ou encore théâtre 230
spectacles différents sont prévus
programme et réservations à retrouver
sur le site de la ville de versailles
merci beaucoup utilisent alors tout à
l'heure on va parler vous devez lire de
mer aux gros coeur on vous expliquera
pourquoi mais on va aussi parler des
dunes d'une expérience qui va faire
quelque chose qui va se passer demain
sur le marché de maisons laffitte et qui
est aussi quelque chose de ma vie terre
ça et c'est pour les gourmands c'est
pour les gourmands et oui et ce pour la
bonne cause exactement cette eau claire
florence lepron jours
qu'ils sont là oui
pâtisserie sait rien de ce soir
oui tout à fait on est tout le temps de
goût c'est aussi une gymnastique c'est
une gymnastique blanc racontez nous un
peu votre parcours parce que vous n'êtes
pas une pâtissière pour fessiers même
nom alors je suis passionné de
pâtisserie depuis que j'ai 8 ans voilà
et lors du premier confinement j'ai
monté cette équipe de bénévoles au début
on a fait des gâteaux pour les soignants
qui n'avait plus le temps de se nourrir
voilà dans les hôpitaux dans les ehpad
et c est moi je les ai tendu j'ai décidé
de l'étendre mon équipe est vraiment
génial et me suis en et une quarantaine
dans l'équipe du québécois se faire
opérer des vols se servir tout à fait le
vol de maisons laffitte et du
mesnil-le-roi voilà et puis là on a par
exemple une pâtisserie qui nous suivent
la pâtisserie de longueuil voilà il ya
beaucoup de commerçants aussi qui nous
offre en organise une tombola aussi
demain donc des commerçants qui nous
offre des lots voilà donc c'est un
véritable
c'est une vraie chaîne de solidarité et
il ya un vrai enthousiasme et un bel
accueil
de la part de la part des habitants de
josette touzet sur le marché vous êtes
alors demain on sera sur le marché on
nous a accordé la mairie nous a accordé
un stand voilà et son mauvais demain
samedi et de 8h30 à 13h il y aura
vraiment énormément de choix donc il ya
quand même quelques pâtissière pro des
traiteurs à domicile puis les personnes
comme moi passionnés de pâtisseries
photo mh d'abord avec
expliquer ce qui se passe
voilà donc en fait je suis passionné
pâtisserie j'étais dans les relations
presse et la communication ce qui n'a
rien à voir avec avec ce que je fais
aujourd'hui voilà d'autres la crème
bulli et l'autre alors demain à
maisons-laffitte donc vous avez vous
hâte sur le marché cet or tout à fait
vous l'aude et les pâtisseries oui
absolument
les sommes recueillies on les verseaux
lyon ce club qui va acheter des cartes
de piscine pour les enfants et les
mamans réfugiés ukrainienne voilà pour
les vacances en fait ils vont rester là
pendant deux mois ils sont loin de leur
famille
enfin dans une situation qui est
difficile pour eux non c'est une
activité qui aura plus d'écoles donc une
activité comme ça pour eux c'était c'est
extra la piscine et les grandes agréable
et ça leur permet aussi de se réunir ce
qui est important donc
il ya cette solidarité autour autour
d'eux en même temps je termine
parce que ça soit prêt pour demain comme
je suis et je pense vous êtes tout seul
de mon nom il vous avez des bénévoles
avec vous on est on est nombreux il ya
une personne du lion's-club dossier qui
vient nous aider non non non on sera
on sera je sais pas une petite dizaine à
être sur le marché voilà non non je suis
pas seul heureusement jugera que je ne
ferais pas parfait mais bien sûr alors
on va passer ou de gauche
qu'est ce qu'il ya dedans moi ça
m'intrigue de
ganache bounty avec un but chocolat au
lait et de la noix de coco tu horrifié
voilà et j'ai d'autres parfums de la
confiture de framboises maisons
de là une ganache vanille de tahiti
et une autre ganache caramel beurre salé
s'est passé
alors c'est pas juste
c'est joli c'est devenu comme tous
les autres millions d'avoir voulu
demeurer
l'inclusion et union durable
j'ai un petit peu mais c'est
ça ça va car enfin bon c'est un peu
comme des vacances et garçons désarmés à
celui de macarons à billets
absolument
donc les enfants c'est vrai que c'est
luiz après là c'est attrayant absolument
et puis ça change un peu des macarons
classique car on a l'habitude de les
nourrir il
a toujours pareil quoi oui ça c'est un
bon et puis après on peut varier en
fonction de la ganache voyez il ya une
autre de mes bénévoles qui elle fera des
macarons mojito spéculoos un film colle
à
tous les goûts oui
énormément en fait on s'est vraiment on
communique beaucoup et du coup on essaye
de faire des choses variées pour
proposer voilà des choses un peu
différentes et
et qu'il y en ait pour tous les goûts
avec c'est comme ça là comme le panda
les enfants doivent adorer ça non ah oui
j'adore oui oui tout à fait ben oui ça
les met en joie le but c'est de susciter
l'envié et est de récolter un maximum de
fonds donc voilà c'est ce que ces biens
peut manger
ses moules étaient de cookies
vegan végal parce qu'il n'ya pas des
faits il n'y a pas de beurre je mets de
l'huile de noisette du sucre rouler que
je compte avoir des goûts qui ya pas de
viande donc je sais pas compliqué mais
c'est vrai qu'avec un bluff mais tout à
y gagner sans rien et si les gars n'ont
pas du tout
c'est vraiment pour qu'il y en ait pour
tous les goûts donc voilà on veut
vraiment et au fait une offre et puis et
puis récoltée je vous dis un maximum de
fonds 6 voilà beaucoup apporté
on peut dire un peu le prix donges pas
une boîte de quatre comme ça la dernière
fois on nous a vendu 5 euros alors on
trouvait que c'était peut-être pas mais
il ya beaucoup de personnes en fait moi
j'ai voulu qu'on fixe des prix assez
accessible pour les jo puisque ce soit
accessible à tout le monde et si les
gens voulaient participer il participait
en plus et souvent ils nous demandent
nous donnait enfin voilà ils nous
donnaient plus ça donc
je présente avec les courtisent je sais
pas si vous pouvez les puits les montres
et patrice peut-être aller confie je
garde ce garçon pas très bien d'autres
coûts qu'ils avaient ghana avec des ben
voilà enfin ben oui elle a n'ont pas
failli à notre succès ça fait débat y
compris jay fait normaux mais aurait
finalement cela
n'a vraiment pour tout le monde à la
bombe
a donc pas sur lui je loue
ya une odeur de satisfaire les biberons
parce que si vous permet de gagner un
atelier pour des réfugiés en fait des
réfugiés ukrainienne tous les samedis on
organise des goûters pour les des
ateliers pour les réfugiés et les
réfugiés ukrainienne qu'en tête je leur
avais fait des petits pandas la semaine
dernière m'ont demandé enfin m'ont dit
mais c'est ce que c'est facile à faire
j'aurais aimé oui vous inquiétez pas et
je vais je vais vous montrer je vais
vous apprendre et on doit organiser un
atelier cet été ajoute il a réalisé vous
êtes tout à fait pour leur apprendre à
faire des macarons comme ça mais bien
voilà
vous allez donc finir les fins
d'émission ah oui tout en plateau de ces
jalousies
pour avoir prédit vivre l'avancée
vers nous on va rester dans la gastro
lui avec patrick avec patrick je crois
toujours à jour alors ce que vous avez
dit et
on entend abbaoui la musique vous
reconnaissez patrick j'écoutais du fait
de la
non il faut qu'on devine mais bon
de récents resteront alors tout à fait
je vous parlais de la bouffe
bouffe est ce que j'ai réellement de la
gastronomie des records plus
pointilleuses mende étoiles alors est ce
que vous connaissez le guide michelin
get rich là c'est le guide qui fait et
quand on ouvre le guide un chien ce
petit livre rouge donc en trouve pour
les yvelines dans les yvelines on trouve
cette étoile pour cette 7e journée toile
et voilà seize restaurants toilettes
infirmerie
c'est comme une étoile ens et ça et
chacun à une seule et téléphone c'était
superbe de la bienvenue mais il est
assez dur alors
c'est donc vous allez nous ne donnait
liste au fonds d'aidé 17 restaurants
étoilés juste une petite question avant
d'aborder chacun de ces restons comme il
faut compter si on veut dîner dans un
restaurant étoilé d'une étoile dans les
yvelines sur les une étoile il faut
compter entre 100 et 200 euros d'être
fonction de l'établissement dans lequel
on va être mais attention évidemment il
n'ya pas les boissons avec des voleurs d
accompagnement souvent c'est restera une
étoile vous font on va dire un petit
panel entre 40 et 50 60 euros pour pour
accompagner les premiers à cheval blanc
évidemment
station en fonction des centres dans
lesquels vous allez vous allez avoir
cinq places il place la dégustation ont
chacun leur nom mais vous qui êtes belge
vous prenez des bières
il faut dire qu'avec et belges y avait
juste une petite question à vous poser
avant que vous avez bradé des restos
allez c'est parce que vous êtes les
grands spéciste de la frite c'est vrai
quelle est la spécificité de la frime
belge la spécificité il y en a plusieurs
en fait la première c'est que ça cuit
dans une graisse de boeuf voilà c'est ça
la grande est
la vraie magie de l'afrique il ya
quelques oui c'est la magie de la fiat
doblo pulsions ou patrice une première
cuisson pour blanchir afrique dakar
souvent prendre bintz et de la pomme de
terre la grosse pomme de terre jaune on
l'a fait cuire à 160° juste pour la
blanche il est sain il faut pas trop
trop chelem est l'auteur ou l'oubli ou
lyon le laisse de côté et le canton veut
les manger on passe la friteuse à 180
degrés et là on a plus qu'à les faire
dorer vous avez une frite croquante sur
le populaire et moelleuse on dit
sous les étoiles
c'est juste pour les frites ah non non
non c
est là pour me dédouaner et on commence
par ses trois adversaires que je crois
c'est ça exactement donc ce qu'on les
trouve c'était se rend alors pour
commencer je ils sont pas dans leurs
devoirs vu qu'ils sont sept après c'est
des choses commencent à versailles comme
ans voilà par la cité royale de tafer
patrice autour du château où nous
trouvons nos trois premiers restaurants
lors le premier c'est le gordon ramsay
donc le gordon ramsay qui au trianon
palace est un des établissements qui n'a
plus à prouver sa notoriété avec sa
cuisine délicate et raffinée qui
s'inspire du restaurant londonien du
même chef du new étoiles y est vous
parlez que je vous parlais comme un
guide
vous y trouverez le chef frédéric
l'argument qui dirige une cuisine
créative
non mais ça l'a dit alors c'est un des
restaurants très grand restaurant
classique de versailles a eu plusieurs
grands chefs avons eu gérard vié qu'il
qu'il a créé il ya très longtemps
après il y avait simone et zain qui est
aujourd'hui au george qui était cultivé
au chef non c'est vrai que c'est un très
gros restant alors de l'autre côté du
parc on va trouver le festin qui est
niché dans le tout nouvel hôtel le grand
contrôle adacore voilà alors c'est aussi
comment le nouvel élu des étoiles et du
département puisque
il a été créé et monté par le champion
du monde des étoiles j'ai nommé juste
ducasse
alain ducasse c'est ça il vous fait
l'essai il a des cheveux courts de trois
étoiles c'est incroyable c'est un
champion du monde elle vous fera voyager
dans les splendeurs de la cour et les
fastes d'antan dans un décor à couper le
souffle
et paraît-il on pourrait parfois ils
croisaient louis xiv louis xv le dpg
dray qui revisite je crois des plats
historique et 2
les gens costumés
ça c'est ça c'est c'est très festif se
doute pas de données mais c'est si on
veut faire une grosse pour eux le menu
signature donc cinq plats en à 140 euros
et l'accord avec le vin on a 80
donc on est sur du 220 euros par
personne domenech m'a donné pas donné le
prix de l'excellence moi oui mais on
peut aller prendre un thé l'après-midi
nous y voilà alors oui oui je pourrais
payer plus modiques voit la visite est
dévié devant le cadre à l'appel c'est un
tout nouvel hôtel qui est apparemment
comme on disait
alors un petit peu plus loin on à la
table du onze qui a accolé à la cour de
santos vous connaissez la cour de ces
voix là avec son jeune chef de 25 ans
jean baptiste lavergne mourad zinc
qui vous propose une cuisine élégante et
soignée qui sublime les saveurs les
couleurs et les textures de ses produits
sélectionnés avec joie et amour je sais
très bien c'est parfait mais il n'en
avait cessé un très bon très bon
restaurant la table du haut et je
signale que si jamais vous voulez pas il
ya aussi le bistrot du onze qui était
une des clés des autres restaurants et
qui est aussi une excellente à blois
très bon mental n'est plus maudit que je
pense être un peu moins cher évident que
le restaurant lui même alors donc du
coup on va quitter le château de
versailles pour un autre château celui
de dampierre
où se trouve la table des bleus dirigés
par le chef christophe blot non voilà
qui réinvente des recettes de sa
grand-mère avec finesse et originalité
patrice de sa
fille parce que c'est vrai et c'est bien
parce que d'empiré bay ça fait pas si
longtemps que ça enfin il ya quelques
années bien qu'il a une étoile mais
c'est vrai que c'est il ya pendant
longtemps il n'y a pas de restaurants
étoilés à dampierre ce qui est dommage
car avec une superbe vue sur le château
superbe vraiment juste en face du
château
donc passons maintenant à marly le voit
pour le restaurant le village tenu d'une
main de maître par attention tommy
heroes you do
japonaise a fait sa cuisine
d'inspiration franco japonaise très
maîtrisée pour une évasion garantie
batterie
sur le solde ils s'écoutent du défunt
des chefs japonais qui apprennent
l'estonie française il faut des choses
absolument remarquable c'est vraiment
génial et j'ai lu dans les sur internet
qu'il paraît que dans son restaurant en
cuisine on y parle japonais figurez-vous
autiste aux japonais la mode et ça vous
étonne
ii faudra
donc ensuite on part pour la direction
du tremblay sur mauldre pour le numéro
trois c'est là que julie et laurent
trochain vous accueilleront pour un
savant mélange de cuisine du terroir et
de cuisine gastronomique dans un cadre
tout à fait élégant
et restent septièmes
gemini prenons de la hauteur au domaine
de la corniche pour le panoramique qui
offre gratuitement une vue spectaculaire
sur la vallée de la seine harold quoi
exactement son chef guettant faire une
li vous servira une cuisine créative et
innovante
c'est un pur l'oise c'est sur la scène
vraiment sur le sud et sud sud yvelines
ce qui serait bien c'est gagner une
carte vous avez on puisse voir c'est
justement je propose pour terminer je
vous propose
je vous propose d'écouter
de jeter un coup d'oeil rapide sur cette
constellation yvelinoise pour mieux
visualiser
toutes les étoiles scintillantes en
musique s'il vous plaît
on met en musique un peu plus fort
qu'avant une réaction est tellement
vous le panoramic le dernier mot le
prochain challenge dont vous allez vous
allez toucher les essayer vous
êtes heu non ce sera aux frais de la
redécouvrir l'appétit merci beaucoup
c'est justin mutti des chocobos peut
passer maintenant mon trouverai
quelqu'un de mer activement au
grand-quevilly il va recevoir qui sont
jean baptiste aveni qui le maire de
wimereux ça et cédric penryn qui est le
père de port-maria mali bonjour
ça va bonjour bonjour alors des ravis de
vous recevoir parce que on va parler
d'une opération à laquelle vous
participez alors on est très admiratif
de ce que vous savez faire mais on va
peut-être raconté d'abord puisque ces
deux opérations faites pour
l'association mécénat chirurgie
cardiaque qui a été créée par le
professeur le cas
francine leca qui est une fabrique sans
dire que je crois qu'ils habitent à
villes pro chez vous non à lévis le
podium je vais rencontrer sur les routes
du tour de france alors que le tour
passait justement dans la commune de
villepreux puisque mécénat est
effectivement partenaires étaient dans
la caravane à ce moment là où j'ai
rencontré le professeur le cas et son
fils et puis bah tout de suite ça a été
un petit coup de coeur et on a eu envie
de se rencontrer sur le des risques à
l'extraordinaire comme femme
vous racontez c'est la vie c'est la
première femme chirurgien cardiaque en
france tu es chef de service elle s'est
spécialisée dans la chirurgie cardiaque
infantile et pourquoi elle a créé cette
association si je me trompe ou vous
reprenez c'est parce que dans un certain
nombre de pays nous demander des pays
d'afrique depuis 10 ans fin là il ya des
enfants qui ont des malformations
cardiaques et on ne s'est pas les opérés
sur place ils ne peuvent être sauvés que
si on les amène en france centre des
services qui peuvent et opéré et le but
de mécénat chirurgie cardiaque c'est ça
c'est de prendre ses enfants de les
amener dans des familles d'accueil qui
les gardent pendant pendant combien de
mois de trois mois après un peu près de
les opérer et de développeurs rendra la
vie comme elle dit après il joue au foot
quoi c'est formidable 1 c'est ça
non c'est participer plutôt tombé par bp
a beaucoup de deux parce qu'ils sont ils
sont très forts elle est le partenaire
du tour de france il y avait aussi des
choses avec l'équipe de france de
football il va t-on par y avait là fait
énormément de choses avec elle ce qu'on
peut dire là dessus et évidemment cédric
pour un poids à me dire un peu la vision
qu'il en a mais c'est vrai que
ils ont sauvé aujourd'hui plus de 4000
enfants un enfant une opération normale
du coeur c'est entre 40 et 50 millions
euros et avec mécénat 12000 euros entre
guillemets suffisent pour pouvoir sauver
un enfant donc l'objectif qu'on s'est
fixé avec cette association les amis du
coeur c'est d'embarquer nos deux villes
le port alignés et villepreux dans cette
histoire de coeur dans cette aventure
avec ce projet de dire deux villes vont
lever deux fois douze mille euros pour
sauver deux vies deux enfants deux
enfants se trouvaient là et là c'est
vrai qu'il ya évidemment pour récolter
de l'argent va y avoir un certain nombre
d'opérations je crois qu'il ya un
concert est prévu il ya une soirée gala
c'est seulement quand même deux concerts
qui sont prévues il y en a un à wimereux
ou pas mal vu avec une initiative des
initiatives assez sympa à chaque fois
puis différents événements il y aura un
gala à un gala qui se tiendra aux
pyramides qui est l'un de nos
partenaires au port marly avec un site
cette sublime où on accueillera
l'ensemble des ensembles des volontaires
de ceux qui ont randonné ou de ceux qui
souhaiteront s'investir à nos côtés on a
d'autres événements aussi d'autres
évènements que mais qu'on avait
habituellement dans la ville et qu'on
dédie cette fois ci à un devis pour de
vie et donc la course de la colonne
bientôt à lui preuve
le premier week-end de juillet
effectivement on a l'habitude d'avoir à
villepreux une colonne donc c'est très
familial koller rome c'est une course
très courte 2 3 km très familial ou et
bien il ya des obstacles et puis parents
et enfants viennent courir l'aspergé de
couleurs de poudre colorée c'est très
festif d'où le mot colonnes alors là je
pense que vu qu'on l'a fait au profit de
mécénat chirurgie cardiaque donc les
escales ronger y aura un peu plus de
rouge
quand je suis passé que les télés 78
et tout un tas d'événements assez sympa
le prochain étant le festival à face qui
va l'insula qui se tient au port-marly
c'est la première édition c'est ça sera
une c'est le 24 25 juin d'une petite
édition l'an dernier formidable touché
par la grâce qui marche est
formidablement est donc cette année en
renouvelle en un peu plus grand c'est
autour de la musique musique
électronique les impressionnistes
surtout au coeur du sujet et ce sera ce
type d'événement et c'est assez sympa
qui accompagneront l'initiative des
équipes du coeur des ballons de musique
pour des battements de coeur et puis c
une course qui est prévu donc vous allez
courir voisine vous allez
[Rires]
vous allez payer de votre personne on
s'est dit bon on a ce projet là on veut
embarquer tout le monde à nous de
montrer l'exemple on vous y en début
d'émission que vous étiez admiratif vous
nous le dirait si bien vivant on
s'embarque quand même dans une aventure
un peu folle on part faire le half
marathon des sables de fuerteventura
donc on part pour entre 100 et 120 km de
course sur trois jours pleins de courses
il y aura une journée de coupure et on
part en autosuffisance alimentaire donc
on aura tout d'un autre paquetage pour
les trois-quatre jours et on dormir en
bivouac eux le soir moi personnellement
je m'en doutais un peu le vent et les
ordis parce que ce que vous avez pas dit
c'est qu'on veut être km entre jour ses
mais pour une belle aux
usa c'est une belle cause bon alors
enfin l'effort
et se prépare au regard du temps et
souvient exactement j'ai dit en visant
douteux
très désobligeant c'est vrai que c'est
un peu affiné devait être papa pour la
dernière fois je pense que j'ai eu la
pression
au travail et spectral vraiment pensé de
cette course-là qu'une petite course en
russie ne m'ont même pas peur
donc votre union il ya une élue des
yvelines qui a déjà fait ce marathon et
bah je me demandais de vous donner
quelques concerts y sont mais dit qu'on
l'a pas fait on gave you as c'est bien
dommage
celle entre le père et c'est bien ce qui
inquiète élus à poissy qui a fait aussi
le 9 barateau alors voilà dit fais
attention sac à dos pape à apporté trop
trop trop lourd
voilà donc ce que c'était mais vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure l'idée le
professeur le calme dit très bien c'est
à nous d'aller faire quelques choses
qu'on aimerait que ses enfants puissent
faire un jour puis s'en aller forcément
jusqu'à un marathon où une course de
cette ampleur et pouvoir taper dans un
ballon pouvoir courir pour pouvoir faire
un peu de sport et donc c'est ça
l'objectif aussi c'est d'aller mouiller
le maillot et d'aller faire de les faire
monter un peu le cardio dans le rouge un
peu pensé que ça avec le cas mais
justement pour que ces gamins-là puisse
peut être un peut s'identifier récolter
les fonds nécessaires pour qu'il puisse
avoir cette opération alors on va faire
une joue soit on trouve quelqu'un dans
la rédaction y ait assez
assez dingue pour vous suivre rexel et
faire le marathon avec vous soit 6 aussi
si sûr tout cela
vous enverrai les images on peut faire
ça mais vous avez vous aimé je vois
regard et femmes
faire des reportages à droite à gauche
dans le département moi je pense qu'ils
peuvent faire le taux facial vous on va
essayer de faire ça
ça serait bien non
en tout cas bravo pour cette initiative
bravo aussi à francine leca parce que ça
fait des années qu'elle se bat avec
cette association et qu'elle fait des
choses absolument formidable c'est
suivre de voir le regard d'aidé de ses
enfants une fois qu'il a été c'est vrai
que s'il était resté dans leur pays d
origine et voilà et certains ne seraient
pas serait pas vivant certains
pourraient enfin c'est vrai une vie très
diminuée et là et voilà c'est formidable
quoi le mot peut-être dans les braquages
collecte oui à la mairie on peut parler
parce que l'idée effectivement c'est de
pouvoir récolter et collecter ces deux
fois 2000 euros donc c'est vrai qu'à
présenter tout un tas d'actions qui vont
se faire jusqu'à notre départ mais après
il y aura d'autres aussi à notre tour si
on revient et la page collecte existe
déjà sur le site de mécénat chirurgie
cardiaque une histoire de coeur il
suffit de taper ça avec mécénat
chirurgie cardiaque il ya un lien qu'on
met sur tous nos compte instagram
beaucoup sur instagram sur facebook sur
twitter et là on veut d'ores et déjà bah
oui et je crois qu'on n'est pas loin de
2 pas loin de 1500 1600 euros je voulais
alors pour l'instant on n'a pas encore
commencé mais ça déjà ça déjà amorcée
sur la page sur le site de mécénat
chirurgie cardiaque vous y allez vous
pouvez donner pour des opérations qui
s'appelle une histoire de glisse dans
son coeur avec avec vous deux bravo se
marie
c'est très bien c'est une très belle
initiative
bah on peut que les féliciter et
d'autres maires se mobilisent que notre
mère se mobilisent ça serait bien mieux
sur le plateau vous raconter comment ça
s'est passé avec plaisir ah oui mais
d'abord on va suivre appelé les
événements jusqu'ici jusque jusque là
parce que ça c'est en septembre c'est ça
170 du 25 septembre au 2 octobre
bizarrement je partais c'est le soir du
concert dansé à exactement le 25
septembre se tiendra le concert qui avec
un nom assez bien choisi c'est alors
c'est un coeur d'enfant pour un choeur
d'enfants puisque on aura des choristes
qui soient des enfants avec la pms qu
l'association qui promeut la musique
classique sur saint quentin qui sera
donc au domaine de grand'maisons à
villepreux avec des enfants de dix ans
indique domaine exactement des enfants
qui viendront chanter et donc ce concert
évidemment caritatif permettra aussi de
collecter des fonds donc c'est vrai que
c'était assez vite trouvée c'est un
coeur d'enfant pour un deux choeurs
d'enfants vous avez parlé du site de
mécénat chirurgie cardiaque ou on peut
participer et donner est-ce que sur les
sites de vauville il ya aussi des
c'est pas des pages où on peut
participer données ou être au tout cas
être renseignés sur les événements qui
ont lieu on a décidé d'engager nos
villes dans l'aventuré zone à sa culture
nos équipes ont suivi directement il n'y
a pas eu besoin de beaucoup d'arguments
pour les convaincre et donc les villes
relaieront des initiatives mais avant ça
il ya aussi tous les réseaux sociaux
qu'on a tenu à mettre en place sur
lesquels on peut être suivi sur laquelle
on retrouve tous les liens tous les
événements et les liens vers le site de
mécénat chirurgie cardiaque aussi c'est
les élus du coeur systématiquement ce
qui permet de me suivre mais c'est
fascinant on diffusera à la fois on
commence à diffuser les entraînements
avec la petite mascotte de mécénat
chirurgie cardiaque qui sont pas là
aujourd'hui parce qu'elles sont en train
de s'entraîner
c'est bien tu es la plus des images
qu'on vous enverra si personne ne les
types n'ont pas envie
ça serait bien
relais aussi par reparle par les comptes
des villes mais c'est vrai comme le dit
cédric les canaux de grande diffusion
instagram facebook twitter linkedin
aussi revient de créer une page c'est
les élus du coeur au profit de profit de
mécénat et puis surtout on profite
d'être là pour vous dire que on est
encore en recherche de familles
d'accueil ah oui ça là il faut une
seconde famille d'accès c'est important
c'est un engagement d'être une famille
d'accueil faut le savoir
puisqu'il faut recevoir l'enfant chez
soi
l'accueillir comme si c'était son propre
enfant ça dure on disait ça dure à peu
près pas de nous deux mois à peu près 7
m'a juste une préparation quelques jours
absolument
mais
le retour peut avoir des familles
d'accueil c'est leur bonheur 1 pour une
soirée on nous donne on a une famille
d'accueil historique par marly qui
accueillait et j'ai pu connaître des
enfants qui ont été accueillis dans ce
cadre là c'est assez formidable les
liens qui se créent on n'a pas idée
parce qu'on se dit c'est difficile et
francine locale le disait le professeur
le cas le disais à mieux que quiconque
c'est compliqué de quitter sa famille
riche spécialement pour les briquets et
finalement ils sont accueillis dans un
milieu tellement bienveillant tellement
accueillants que ça se passe
formidablement et il ya des biens qui se
crée qui se créent advitam puisque en
plus et ça leur permet de vivre de vivre
réellement et avec des souvenirs à ses
fantasmes ses voisins et comme dit le
professeur le cas c'était cette victoire
et ça doit être vrai quoi c'est les
familles quand dans l'enfance mais
remanger a bien mangé et voilà elle
serait heureuse et cs dick ça y est quoi
est il et il est sauvé donc alors ce
qu'elle disait aussi je suppose qu'on
peut le penser si vous êtes des jeux de
retraités par exemple il paraît que
c'est parmi eux comme comme famille
d'accueil parce que voilà c'est des gens
qui voient la culture en pleine pleine
activité si on peut dire bienvenue avec
des personnes qui vont un peu plus de
temps à raconter aux enfants
logiquement leurs propres enfants ont
déjà quitté le domicile familial donc il
ya de la disponibilité il ya peut-être
aussi des ressources parce que ce qu'il
faut quand même dire c'est que le temps
même s'il est assez bref le temps
d'accueil est à la charge des familles
et je lis un accompagnement
psychologique morale un accompagnement
global de mécénat derrière mais le temps
que l'enfant est là c'est tout famille
évidemment de se financer cet accueil
mais oui on lance un appel parce que
littéralement on aimerait avoir une
famille d'accueil en marres lille 20
et là aussi sur le site des villes on
peut on peut trouver des renseignements
pour ce alors vraiment comme le faisait
cédric surtout sur les élus du coeur on
aura dans nos magazines respectifs l'âme
on nous l'avait promis il sort fin juin
le magazine municipal on aura acquis les
beautés dans toutes les boîtes aux
lettres de la commune une page sur cette
initiative avec un appel pour les
familles d'accueil et toutes les
informations nécessaires à la fois sur
la collecte s'est donc
merci beaucoup les gens mettent une
mousse que c'est bien vous allez courir
je voudrais pas pour
notre journaliste sportif les littoraux
appelle les deux rives portugais pour ça
qu'ils espèrent
merci merci
[Musique]
merci de votre accueil
justin
j'aimerais bien savoir comment vous
intéressez pas plutôt latin mais comment
je prends la ministre
américaine clément qui vous attend donc
pas de souci là-dessus demain samedi 11
juin avec quelques nuages seront
présents sur l'ensemble du département
avec un léger vent du nord-ouest de 15
km heure ce sera sur la journée au
niveau des températures le matin il fera
16 degrés à rambouillet 18 à versailles
et mantes la jolie à des éclaircies sont
prévues dans l'après midi le mercure
grimpera à 23° à rambouillet 24 à
versailles pour dent et molle dimanche
selon les prévisions actuelles le soleil
elle sera présent sur l'ensemble des
yvelines il fera 12 devait à rambouillet
14° à mantes la jolie ou encore
qu'attend 15° pardon à versailles le
matin et pour l'après midi toujours sur
le sous le soleil avec toujours un petit
un petit vent de 15 km prévu 15 km heure
prévus sur le territoire elle les
températures devraient être prévues sur
l'ensemble du département entre 22 et 23
degrés quand un jeu est en fait un beau
week end merci encore
et
les dons vous laissez vous entraîner la
vallée nous parlait aussi d'un projet
ans depuis le mois de septembre 29
élèves de 3e du collège saint-augustin
de saint germain en laye ont découvert
le cinéma d'animation donc les
techniques l'envers du décor mais c'est
la pratique au travers de la réalisation
d'un court métrage est donc ce dernier
étaient diffusées lors d'un mapping la
semaine c'est ça la semaine dernière un
mapping en fait c'est une projection qui
est fait sur les bâtiments en battant le
court métrage été diffusé en soirée donc
il devait être 22 heures 22 heures à peu
près vingt deux heures trente ce qu'il
faut forcément képi de soleil et c'était
diffusé donc sur le bâtiment directement
du collège et donc on a pu assister
et donc comme vous l'avez dit il sont
ils sont passés derrière l'écran le
temps d'une année en fait ils ont été
initiés à la technique papiers découpés
donc on va en voir des images dans
quelques instants ils ont appris à nîmes
et des personnages et des paysages et ce
mapping là dont on parle et c'est un
aboutissement pour les élèves après donc
un an mais quatre mois de travail du
coup sur ce court métrage pour ce projet
donc on les avait suivis vous les voyez
pendant la préparation ni d'ailleurs le
reportage est à retrouver sur nos
réseaux sociaux si ça vous intéresse
donc il y avait un intervenant technique
qui leur a appris la technique image par
image justement donc c'est un dispositif
stop motion qui est installé on le voit
la voilà c'est exactement si ces
collégiens de ce décalage de troisième
donc en troisième on doit avoir 13 ans p
oui 14 14
il faut les dessins sont les
déconstructions aussi un exactement en
fait ce qui était très sympathique c'est
que c'était vraiment un travail
collectif en fait chacun avait une tâche
est donc bah y'en a qui s'occupait de
faire un personnage en a qui s'occupait
de faire un paysage est en fait pas loin
d'un qui a pas un sanglier puis l'art qu
il la reconnaît justement sur son court
métrage on voit le sanglier qui s'anime
chaque heure avait quelque chose à faire
est donc donc voilà ça c'était c'était
très sympa avant qu'ils ont construits
ils ont réalisé cette vidéo ensemble
pendant quatre mois et donc notre pro
team notre petit monde c'est le court
métrage dont qui traitait de la
civilisation en fait c'est le cycle de
la vie un peu donc commencer démarre il
y avait les dinosaures ensuite il ya ces
détruit ensuite il ya les bâtiments avec
la civilisation exactement je les ai vus
c'est
certain c'est quoi ag toi ça formidable
et comme monsieur vous quand j'ai vu
enfin que c'était en effet les
collégiens que je fais ça incroyable
quoi yable avec la la musique et audard
c'est vrai que c'est pas ya une émotion
particulière je trouve une ambiance il
ya du sérieux du temps de faire entrer
les relations c'est quand même très
exact je le dis maintenant il y avait
moyen qui avec avec
l'informatique ce qu'ils permettent
quand même d'aller beaucoup plus vite qu
autrefois où il fallait faire
qui les ont dessinés ils ont fait plus
ample ans ils ont pris à l'image c'est à
dire qu'en fait j'avais un appareil
photo qui étaient là eux il animé en
fait sous forme de pantin parce qu'ils
ont fait des images fin des dessins
découpé en fait et a pris les ont animés
comme des pantins donc il émettait un
arbre et puis prenez une photo à chaque
fois on s'était tous périr ça fait
quatre mois est en fait et ce qui est
une petite anecdote à savoir c'est que
en fait elle est collégien n'avait pas
vu le court métrage avant la projection
c'était en fait ils ont terminé le jeudi
et le mardi c'était diffusé sauf qu'en
fait l'intervenant la balle a réalisé
entre nîmes et la vidéo le week-end et
n'avait pas vu la vidéo il était hyper
fier bayonne quoi on voit l'arrivée tous
les parents d'élèves qui étaient là
c'était vraiment une fierté pour eux
s'ils voulaient au courant à ce qu'on
gagne peut-être un extrait
[Musique]
c'est super ça leur salaire vraiment
dedans très sympa royaume on va on le
doit à la presse à des nationaux pour
cette émission diffusée et on va
diffuser du coup l'émission et
ça dure 4 minutes
réalité mais c'est vraiment sympa à voir
n'hésitez pas deux roues c'est grâce à
vous
ping juste ajuster après donc mardi
dernier avril lapping c'était vraiment
très sympa mais même en vidéo ça vaut le
coup d'oeil merci beaucoup justin merci
à vous merci beaucoup c'est violent
merci patrice et ben voilà on se
retrouve très vite je pense pour un
nouveau 7 8 je disais dream team gym
comme tôt qu'un faux et magazines et
avec toute la rédaction remercie toute
la rédaction de tv 68 qui s'est mobilisé
pour pour cette émission donc à très
vite pour une nouvelle émission et
encore bravo c'est bien merci
[Musique]